[Music]
doc brown's nephew mrs potato head and a
pt anderson favorite these are the
seinfeld stars who are no longer with us
monk's cafe in seinfeld is as much a
character as the actors on screen and
its human embodiment is ruthie cohen the
cashier who appears in a whopping 101
episodes of the show uncredited and
unnamed ruthie might not always get a
speaking line but during the show's nine
seasons she appeared in the most
episodes besides the core cast of jerry
elaine george and kramer
with her mop of curly hair sometimes
blue uniform and kindly demeanor ruthie
is one of the few seinfeld characters
who does no harm to others
her most memorable episode might be the
one where george accuses her of stealing
a 20 bill he still had in his own wallet
actress ruth cohen made a career of
extra work on shows like the golden
girls and murder she wrote with her main
success as seinfeld's most prolific
background star
in 2008 cohen died of a heart attack at
78.
if we want to understand why george
costanza is how he is we need not look
much further than his father frank whose
impotent rage has been passed down to
his dysfunctional and underachieving son
from his obsession with tv guide to his
creation of an alternate december
holiday called festivus that violently
combats the cheer of christmas and
hanukkah and at the festivus dinner you
gather your family around and tell them
all the ways they have disappointed you
over the past year frank costanza is
almost in a class of his own amid the
routine madness of seinfeld he was such
a huge presence in the show it's hard to
believe he was only in 24 episodes frank
was played by hollywood royalty jerry
stiller the father of ben stiller he
brought his signature eccentricity to
the role with all the gusto he could
muster jerry stiller passed away in his
sleep in may 2020 at the age of 96
having spent the last 60 years of his
life making people laugh
while phil bruns originally played
jerry's dad morty seinfeld for his first
appearance on the show it's barney
martin that seinfeld fans remember when
thinking of the character since he
played him for 19 episodes
george and frank are clearly related but
the apple has fallen far from the tree
with morty and jerry the two have very
little in common and that doesn't stop
them from having ridiculous conflicts
take for example the time jerry bought
morty a cadillac after a career boost
instead of enjoying the gift morty got
impeached as the president of the
homeowners association after his
neighbors believed he stole their
collective funds to afford such a sweet
new ride the enmity between morty and
frank costanza was epic and his brief
turn working with elaine at jay peterman
was as weird as it was funny a detective
turned actor barney martin died at 82 of
cancer in studio city california in
2005. he remains best known for his role
as jerry's dad on seinfeld despite an
otherwise storied acting career
in a cast filled with literally hundreds
of memorable weirdos jerry's uncle leo
is arguably one of the strangest the
comedian's relationship with uncle leo a
man so pushy that he resorts to grabbing
people's arms while he's speaking so
that they won't walk away comes to
literally explosive moments like when
one of jerry's packages accidentally
ends up at leo's and blows up even after
it comes to light that uncle leo sparked
the conflagration by leaving a can of
cleaning spray in his oven he still
blames jerry played by prolific
character actor len lesser who appeared
in more than 500 roles during the course
of his long career uncle leo became his
own force of nature in seinfeld in
february 2012 he passed away from
cancer-related pneumonia in burbank
california at the age of 88. bookstore
owners may not miss shoplifting uncle
leo but seinfeld fans sure do
[Music]
hello
if george costanza was insufferable even
to his best friends he was exponentially
worse at work from sleeping with his
assistants and offering them
unauthorized raises to napping under his
desk instead of doing his job george was
a nightmare employee no one was more
baffled or unsettled by his unruly work
behavior than his boss at yankee stadium
mr wilhelm for viewers mr wilhelm's
puzzled and shocked face over his 11
seinfeld episodes often mirrored our own
as we watched george's antics amazed
that the man somehow never got fired in
many ways mr wilhelm feels like one of
the show's few examples of a conscience
all thanks to richard heard's empathetic
portrayal he even made an appearance in
the series finale along with mr
steinbrenner heard had been a familiar
face in both movies and television until
his death in may of 2020 from cancer
complications at the age of 87.
wretched though elaine bennis might be
in her personal life she demonstrates
professionalism at work at least
compared to george unfortunately she has
to contend with bosses who are all
insane to varying degrees this brilliant
comedic reversal makes elaine among the
more fully rounded of all these
all-around awful characters
one of the places where we see her
struggle the most is in her role as
assistant to justin pitt one of double
day publishing's top executives played
by british actor ian abercrombie mr
pitt's quirks almost put cramers to
shame from cutting his snickers bars
with utensils and needing a specific
kind of white sock that must be ironed
before wearing to picking salt off of
pretzels mr pitt is one of elaine's
biggest complaints in the episodes in
which he appears
while abercrombie was best known as mr
pitt he had a long acting career that
began with stage work in the uk and
ended in hollywood many decades later he
passed away from kidney failure
complications in january 2012 at 77
years old
while the majority of seinfeld takes
place inside jerry's manhattan apartment
some of the show's misadventures occur
in the retirement community in florida
where jerry's parents live though
they're supposed to be enjoying their
golden years and relaxing in the sun
nobody in the retirement community got
the memo and certainly not jack klumpus
morty seinfeld's arch nemesis played by
sandy barron another comedy and broadway
legend jack klompus's general suspicion
of the entire seinfeld family culminates
into him accusing morty of stealing
columbus also caused an unnecessary row
after forcing jerry to accept his
special astronaut pen that writes upside
down
okay thank you very much thank you
and then complaining about the incident
to the whole community until jerry gave
it back sandy baron died in february
2001 at the age of 64 after battling
emphysema for a number of years
while seinfeld was always a dark comedy
it had moments where it flirted with
being downright disturbing like in the
ross family arc susan ross was george
costanza's longtime girlfriend and
briefly his fiancee before she died from
licking toxic wedding envelopes george
selected in order to save money played
by twin peaks alumni warren frost and
grace sabrisky mr and mrs ross never
liked george and they made no secret
that they thought he was terrible for
their daughter
by the finale of seinfeld mr ross is
fully convinced that george deliberately
murdered his daughter we even see him
buying a gun presumably in case george
and his friends are acquitted for their
myriad of crimes and social wrongs while
frost's turn as doc hayward and twin
peaks overshadowed his five episodes in
seinfeld fans of the show continue to
remember him fondly he passed away in
february 2017 at the age of 91.
most of george costanza's bosses
expected far more from him than he was
ever able to provide but not mr kruger
of kruger industrial smoothing he
mirrors george's laxadaisical manner in
so many ways played by character actor
daniel von bargin mr kruger has a few
iconic plot lines even though he's only
in four seinfeld episodes his first
major story involves a trip to the beach
with his family and a resulting
photograph that george mucks up
completely his most memorable appearance
arguably comes when george tries to
convince him that his fictional charity
the human fund is real george's attempt
at persuasion ends with kruger joining
him for festivus celebrations at the
costanza home
i find your belief system fascinating
with his deadpan expression and comedic
timing von barjin absolutely steals the
scene a remarkable feat among so many
other talented actors tragically he
passed away in march 2015 at the young
age of 64 after a long battle with
diabetes complications mental illness
and a tragic suicide attempt we first
meet poppy the owner of a well-known
italian pizzeria where jerry starts
dating his daughter audrey the date
takes a disastrous turn when jerry sees
that poppy doesn't wash his hands after
using the toilet this causes the
comedian to refuse to eat the
hand-tossed pizza poppy made especially
for them which insults both father and
daughter in just 4 episodes poppy
manages to cause quite a lot of damage
beginning when a medical condition leads
him to unknowingly urinate on jerry's
new couch poppy's enmity with the group
extends to elaine their conflicting
views on abortion land him in the
hospital due to stress the actor who
played poppy rennie santoni was best
known for his role as clint eastwood's
partner in dirty harry he passed away at
81 in august 2020 after a long illness
you'd think after so many years on air
and in reruns seinfeld would bring us a
little bit closer to understanding how
jerry's brain works but as we see with
the nana subplot his behavior remains a
mystery played by billy ree wallace for
three episodes jerry's nana is minding
her own business when her grandson
suddenly decides to cash all the ten
dollar checks she'd sent him for his
birthday for many many years
because nana no longer has that
particular account anymore the checks
bounce and she gets dressed up in her
finest to go down to the bank and get it
sorted out unfortunately she discovers
the bank isn't there anymore the
neighborhood is scarily run down but she
gets surprisingly good directions from a
random man in an alley like many of her
seinfeld co-stars wallace was a
well-known character actress who
appeared in shows like mad about you as
well as films like albert brooke's
mother in march 1999 wallace passed away
from respiratory failure and emphysema
at the age of 73.
if there's one thing we know for certain
about jerry seinfeld it's that he's
selfish and opportunistic enter mabel
choate an elderly woman who simply wants
a nice marble rye jerry needs a loaf for
george to replace the one that frank
costanza stole from susan's parents so
he steals her bread it's dark out so
mabel doesn't recognize her assailant
until another inopportune moment when
morty seinfeld is being impeached mabel
also testifies against jerry at the
trial in the series finale noting that
he never expressed remorse for stealing
from her a little old lady
for three episodes character actress
frances bay plays mabel bringing
scathing wit and impeccable comedic
timing to the role she passed away at 92
years old in september 2011 after an
accident left her with a series of
health complications
at the end of season 3 kramer gets upset
after jerry takes his keys back and
decides he wants to go to los angeles to
be an actor during his quest to find
fame in showbiz he meets helena a former
actress who haunts the hallways of his
new apartment building played by elmery
wendell elena is a send-up of hollywood
queen norma desmond in sunset boulevard
stealing the show as she descends the
stairs with her sometimes inappropriate
commentary wendell might have been
better known for her turn as mrs dubeck
on third rock from the sun but seinfeld
fans will still be saddened to hear of
her passing in july 2018 of undisclosed
causes she was 89
there are three izzy mandle bombs in
seinfeld is he senior izzy and izzy jr
comedically all three generations appear
to be roughly the same wisened age izzy
is one of morty and helen's neighbors in
florida irritated by jerry's youthful
vigor he challenges the comedian to
feats of strength but ends up throwing
his back out while visiting izzy's sick
bed jerry runs into izzy jr who throws
his back out trying to go jerry into
lifting a hospital television that's
bolted to a table finally izzy
mandelbaum senior appears and you
guessed it lands himself in a hospital
bed as well sadly all three mandelbaum
actors have passed away hollywood icon
lloyd bridges died in march 1998 at 85
after several illnesses gene donerski
passed in april 2020 after a series of
heart issues and mandelbaum patriarch
earl schumann died of undisclosed causes
at 100 years old in march 2016.
in elaine's extensive catalogue of men
who become obsessed with her the
creepiest is definitely ricky played by
christopher lloyd's nephew sam lloyd
when we first meet ricky he's sitting
next to elaine on the subway and offers
her a highlighter for the tv guide she's
reading
his intensity freaks her out and in a
rush to get away from him she forgets
her magazine on the subway seat only
it's not her magazine it's frank
costanzas he's none too pleased when
ricky stalks elaine to the costanza
house with a bizarre bouquet made out of
his tv guide the next time we meet ricky
his obsession has veered into mild
psychopathy he designs mannequins that
look just like elaine which are
distributed all over new york city
unfortunately scrubs actor sam lloyd was
only 55 when he was diagnosed with a
brain tumor and lung cancer he succumbed
to his illness in may 2020 at the age of
56.
seinfeld fans will no doubt remember
walter okowitz from his memorable guest
role in the 1996 two-part episode the
cadillac as nick the cable guy he chased
kramer through the streets of new york
city and later hugged it out with him
after apologizing on behalf of plaza
cable for making him wait at home all
day
new jersey native and best known for his
turn as bartender jacques renault in
twin peaks twin peaks fire walk with me
and later as jacques cousin in twin
peaks the return ulkowitz retired from
acting following several knee surgeries
and later died of complications from
infections in 2021 at the age of 72. his
son screenwriter zack okowitz said in a
statement he was a good man who pushed
his love for creativity and the arts
into everything he did
over the span of 27 episodes of seinfeld
viewers got a chance to see just why
george costanza was the way he was it
was all because of a comically fraught
relationship with his overbearing
overprotective judgmental and often
shrieking mother estelle costanza
you're wearing that shirt
you've had it for five years already why
don't you buy a new shirt
estelle was often a hindrance to
george's goals or a burden to be dealt
with she was great at embarrassing her
son as was the case in her first
appearance in the episode the contest i
go out for a quart of milk i come home
and find my son treating his body like
it was an amusement park
before her signature role of estelle
costanza on seinfeld estelle harris had
a few dozen parts she only began
seriously acting in her late 40s with
frequent theatrical and tv commercial
roles according to cnn after seinfeld
she often played a version of estelle
costanza through voice work most notably
as mrs potato head in the toy story
movies
harris died in april 2022 at the age of
93.
veteran actor philip bakerhall appeared
on screen nearly 200 times in a 50-year
career that stretched from the early
1970s to the 2020s a definitive
character actor he was always noticeable
for his uniquely raspy voice and intense
stare which he brought to dozens of
shows and movies paul was a member of
writer director paul thomas anderson's
repertory players landing major parts in
hard 8 boogie nights and magnolia he was
also part of the award-winning ensemble
of the contender argo and dogville
regardless he is probably best
remembered for the character he played
on one episode of seinfeld which he
reprised in the series finale he
portrayed the wonderfully and aptly
named lieutenant joe bookman the stern
and relentless library cop who tracks
down jerry over a book that was 20 years
overdue
paul died at home in glendale california
in june 2022 he was 90 years old
there isn't anyone on seinfeld who loved
adored and cherished the heart to love
jerry seinfeld more than his mother
helen seinfeld how could anyone not like
you
she visits jerry often at his home in
new york city when he can't make it down
to florida to see her and her husband
morty those visits usually morph into
meddling and budding in verging on
smothering the doting relentlessly sunny
and persuasive helen appeared in 21
seinfeld episodes over the course of the
series playing the nosy helen
immediately after a recurring role as
the nosy neighbor in alf was liz
sheridan a veteran of multiple 70s
broadway productions and many 80s
sitcoms
her representative told deadline that
she died in her sleep in april 2022 she
was 93.
catherine cates portrayed an unnamed but
plot pivotal character in two episodes
of seinfeld that aired two years apart
jerry and delane head to the royal
bakery to purchase a chocolate bobcat
but are unable to because they didn't
take a number when they arrived enabling
someone else to buy the last one they
purchase a lesser cinnamon bobka and
must deal with the busy harried
counterwoman to return it kate pops up
again as the bakery cashier in the 1996
episode the rye once more trying to buy
something at the royal bakery only to
have someone else purchase it right
before he can jerry loses out on a
marble ride to mabel choate which he
infamously gets after mugging her and
taking it a prolific character actor who
appeared in law and order svu and
oranges the new black kates died in
florida in january 2022 after a history
of lung cancer she was 73.
in the episode the breasts jerry and
elaine are asked by some friends to be
the god parents of their new baby in
accordance with that the pair must find
a moil the jewish holy figure who
performs the sacred rite of circumcision
unfortunately the guy they've hired
isn't exactly the best he's prone to
wild mood swings and may have even once
faced malpractice allegations for
botching another breast it all boils
over into a full-on fight between jerry
and the moyle portraying the unnamed but
memorable moyle was character actor
charles levin who apart from seinfeld
was probably best known for the pilot
episode of the golden girls and multiple
woody allen films in july 2019 his
remains were found in a remote area of
oregon where he had gotten lost and
stranded he was 70.
[Music]